hi Carrie how are you great how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call my sister and
I've got a kind of question about
reverse mortgages my sister and I were
signed over how my parents house when we
were younger because my parents were
both getting sick and they were shunned
the house over to us for us to be sure
that it was ours if something would
happen to them however since then my mom
and dad are not separated my mom lived
in Charlotte my dad now lives in the
house that my sister and I have my name
on and my dad has life tenancy and with
that he's supposed to be taking care of
the taxes mortgage and the kind of
taking care of the house in general
however we just got a letter in the mail
saying that he has not paid the taxes
this year and that he was asking for our
help but my sister and I are neither of
us are in any financial state to help
him taxes are about $4,000 and he has
gotten a lawyer to kind of write these
letters back and forth to us why why why
is a lawyer handling or something
between you and your father
exactly
needless to say my dad is he is 73 he's
not in good health and more than likely
the best thing for him to do in my mind
is for him to downsize and not have to
take care of the land that we have and
the house anymore but he wants us to
sign the house back over to him and get
a reverse mortgage and up until this
point we have said no because I've read
all of your articles on it I know it's
not a great idea but he is convinced
that it is a good idea and
unfortunately now we're in a position
where something has to be done well um
so you either have to participate in
madness or on you have to have conflict
right there's not there's not any
options as what he's putting on the
table and so you just gotta decide which
one you want to do because I there's no
way I'm signing I mean if you sign it
over to him he puts reverse mortgage on
it that's participating in madness and
you're just you're just what you're just
washing your hands and walking away now
the other problem you have is you have
tremendous gift tax and in a state tax
potential estate tax problem as well and
I suspect they did not do this properly
when they signed it over to you to start
with that there probably there's no gift
tax addressed at that time and so this
thing's probably this transaction is
probably still hovering out there as
done poorly see you can't just sign your
house over to somebody unless you file
some paperwork called the unified estate
tax credit and use part of your estate
tax credit otherwise it's liable for
gift tax and so if they just up and
signed it over to you if he has a life
estate I assume attorney produced it
hopefully the attorney knew to do it
properly
in which case the only way you can now
give it back to him is use up part of
your estate planning so it affects your
estate plan in the future if you do this
what's the property worth without
getting various items fixed probably 180
grand okay all right well you know it
just depends on how much you want to
fight about it you're going to have to
see a tax professional to get the tax
opinion if you want to deed it back to
him
you have to get some tax input because
you could really cost yourself like
thirty thousand bucks in order to deed
this back to him randomly if you do it
if you do it improperly if you just sign
a deed and hand it back to him you're
going to get nailed with with uh gift
tag
so you've got to see a tax professional
preferably a tax attorney or CPA to get
some on that side of it that that part
aside now what's the principle the
principle is then you've either got to
say okay I'm guessing is that's not like
you guys have a great relationship no
okay I have I have tried and I'm closer
to him than my sister's okay so the
chances of you and your sister sitting
down over the kitchen table and going to
the expense and the trouble of doing
that and going you know going there and
sitting down face-to-face and looking at
I'm going to add this a bad idea instead
let's sell the property let's move you
into a condo and you know get do that
then we'll participate in that but the
chances of you actually talking him into
that are by zero because he's already
got attorneys sending you letters right
and actually due to him not paying the
taxes or taking care of the house it has
come to our attention that we can sell
the house now well you probably you may
have to get a court's permission to do
that you have to have somebody actually
invalidate the life estate in clause
there's a life estate filed as a Clow on
the title and in order for a title
company to write a title insurance
policy they've got to see something to
proves that life estates been removed so
you're probably gonna have to go to
court to get that removed good but you
probably could there's probably grounds
for that because he hasn't helped held
his part of the deal is what you're
saying
and so um but yeah you're gonna have to
go to court to cause that to happen and
then you can sell the property straight
out now your basis in the property for
tax purposes is whatever he paid for it
at the time so you're gonna have capital
gains on all of that so if he paid very
little for it you're going to capital
gains on almost the whole thing so this
is a tangled mess I don't know what to
tell you to do but you're either going
to have to just do what he wants to do
and hand it back to him and just dust
your hands off right just go that's it
washing my hands of this um or you got
to really go down there and try to do
what's right for him and what's the
right thing to do instead of
participating in his madness but as you
do that you and I both know that's going
to involve
right and so when you take a principled
stand on something so that that's you
know what we're looking at here and I
guess you got to decide how much of this
you want to do as an act of love towards
him
and just as an act of principle how much
of these boundaries do we want to set
right you know so even if the conflict
involves just going to court to get the
ruling on the life estate is invalid now
and so now you can just sell the house
which puts him basically in the street
you're still there's obviously conflict
there you can rid of a Victorian father
into the street at that point and you
could use some of the money to house him
or something if you wanted to but he not
like any of that so conflicts there so
you just got to decide do we want to
have the no conflict and let him do the
wrong thing and we just walk away
turn a blind eye to it or are we going
to stand in here and fight our way
through this family toxic mess and sad
that he's putting his own daughters
through this this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you